so several states including new york and
hawaii are still
in the face of this new cdc guidance
refusing to relax their mask
mandates nancy pelosi is on board with
that she's refusing to relax
the relax the mandates in the house of
representatives and she can do that
yesterday florida congressman brian mast
defied that order
madam speaker as the member designated
for the representative from florida
brian mast
i ask that given the updated cdc
guidance we all take off these stupid
masks
so brian mast standing on science spoke
the truth and for that he was threatened
with a
fine for being massless on the house
floor we have reached out to nancy
pelosi's office
and you won't be surprised to learn they
blew us off in declining comment but
congressman brian mask did agree to come
on tonight and we're happy to have him
with us now congressman thanks so much
for coming on before i ask you why every
republican in the house who's been
vaccinated didn't follow suit and do
what you did
let me ask you why you did what you did
i'm just not going to play her stupid
game that
falls somewhere between dog and pony
show
smoke and mirrors and pure manipulation
that's why
so you've been vaccinated the science as
communicated by the cdc
this week current state of it is that
you do not need to wear a mask because
you're not going to get coveted because
that's why you got the vaccination in
the first place
what is her position what is her
argument why is she threatening to find
you for following cdc guidance
because they want control they want
control of everybody and let's put the
perspective on this
the person third in line to the
presidency
is saying this in the house of
representatives if you don't wear a mask
even though the cdc
said you definitely don't need to wear
one and science supports that
you should be fined 500 for the first
offense and a thousand dollars
every time they're after and probably
the reason everybody doesn't follow suit
is because they don't want to be fined
five hundred and a thousand dollars
respectively
so how many republicans are going to
follow your lead into morally justified
civil disobedience in the face of
tyrannical stupid and honestly deranged
requirements like this one how many
others do you think will do what you've
done
you know i think come monday you're
going to see everybody toss their masks
in the air like graduates are tossing
their hats in the air
and say we're just not gonna follow
speaker pelosi's tyrannical rule here
i i gotta ask you i mean we've talked a
lot in this country about addressing
the mental health crisis that that's
clearly hurting
america we're watching a mental health
crisis here and i'm just i'm wondering
how many of the people who are still
wearing masks after having been
vaccinated after reading the cdc
guidance telling them not to wear masks
how many sincere question are suffering
from some form of diagnosable mental
illness
well you got to ask yourself are you
going to use
science as just a tool to support
whatever your agenda is
or are you actually going to take it for
what it is are you going to use it
when it supports or doesn't support
whatever your hypothesis
is and if you're not going to use it in
both circumstances then you're just not
being honest you're not being true
you're not being just
and and that's clearly a problem for
anybody especially somebody that's a
part of representative government
and i'd make one more point on this just
quickly and that's to say this
let's see if they use the same fervor
about protecting yourself
when it comes to us physically
protecting ourselves you know say
personally
with our firearms or things like that i
don't think it will apply for them in
the same situations
let me ask you one last quick question
the science suggests that people who've
recovered from covit and have high
levels of antibodies are in fact
safer from reinfection than people
who've taken the vaccine there are 100
million of those people
in this country why are they wearing
masks
well because they're forced to because
when you go to the grocery store
they force you to or they don't let you
in when you go to the airport they force
you to or they don't let you in that's
the place that they want to get to
to force you to disclose your health
information
or else you will be fined or you won't
be allowed into somewhere
and if you dear health information
doesn't show that you got the vaccine
that they want you to get
and who knows what other vaccines
they'll want you to get into the future
then you won't be able to rejoin society
because that's what they will mandate
that is the control
time to stop playing along and thank you
for leading the way on that congressman
brian mast of florida appreciate it
all the best hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else